the mayor of bristol marvin reese joins
me
um good morning mr mayor um
marvin how significant
how significant is this case for bristol
well it depends on um
your audience depends on your criteria
in the lives of the four individuals
it's incredibly significant uh you know
i guess because their
futures have just you know faced a bit
of a fork in the road in some ways uh
for the work on race inequality
in bristol uh much more widely it's less
significant uh because uh you know my
sense is that you know when we're
tackling race inequality we're looking
at those underlying drivers of uh
political and economic um inequality and
the verdict itself doesn't actually
touch on those uh very uh real and
immediate issues
so in essence you're saying this is
really
as far as bristle concerned a rather
marginal issue
well it it it would be noisy um but i'm
minded of a
something someone said to me the other
day this too shall pass
i mean i you know it's it's one of the
warnings i make
all the time that we have to be careful
about symbolic acts and mere events
that's being substituted for acts of
real substantial systemic
change now make no mistake about it i
know i i don't like the idea of the
statue being up in the middle of the
city i'm glad it's not there um i think
that the debate around our history and
who we choose to celebrate as a country
is important
these are symbols of historical
injustice and whose voice is heard and i
think there needs to be work done on
this and i would like to see people who
have been involved in kidnapped rape and
all the rest of it
not celebrated in public space but at
the same time symbolic acts
while they're important if they begin to
take the place of acts of political and
economic policy and real substance
become a problem
because we look around in five years
realize that nothing's really changed
people point to all these things that
have happened and we say oh but those
were just acts those are just
performances so we have to be very
careful the way we uh we handle these
issues
is that a in a way another way of saying
what uh you said rather strikingly the
other day that people shouldn't come to
bristol in the hope of fulfilling their
revolutionary fantasies um
the problem is you can't stop them can
you
no no but again there needs to be uh
what the fullness of what i said was if
they're coming to do real political
change to do some of the hard yards i
mean not all anti-racism work is done
with a banner and a t-shirt and a
megaphone right some of it's done by
looking at housing policy looking at
affordable
homes looking at what we do around
making sure people are fed making tweets
to our mental health system looking at
the number of magistrates we get and
going out recruiting stuff that we've
done over the last few years that has
not hit their headlines that has not
brought tens of thousands of people onto
the street but led just a few years ago
to
11 of 33 new magistrates in bristol
coming from black and asian backgrounds
that's never happened and yet we know
about the inequalities in the criminal
justice system uh you know that plague
and that's a central part of ongoing
racial inequality
so it's not all about what gets in the
headlines it's about sometimes those
those hard yards done in you know in
invisibility
well it's pretty clear what your what
your priority here is um
and
i just want to ask you this and
forgive me uh we we've know each other
uh outside of this kind of encounter uh
let me ask you a direct question um as
the most senior elected black official
in the united kingdom
not if not in europe how do you feel
about um four white individuals claiming
to represent
uh the feelings of minority bristolians
well
well i i haven't poured over the things
they've been saying other than them and
their barristers saying that we've been
inactive in the city uh which obviously
i've you know got issues with and you
know and i'd be more than happy to talk
to them about what real
anti-racism uh work is i i as again i
think the symbolic acts are really
important and
you know they've played a part in
bristol's history but you're jumping off
my back here and then that takes us into
another realm of conversation more
broadly i think there is a question
about what it means to be an ally and
what allyship is um and you know trevor
i'm not over claiming my significance
but you know first black uh mayor in uk
probably the first black mayor of any
major european city there are challenges
if they are saying that racism is real
then surely they would also have enough
awareness to say there are probably some
issues about race that go with this
black guy becoming mayor you know of
bristol and we want to understand what
those are
before we just railing and start saying
that nothing's happened in the face of
the reality that many things have
actually
happened so so i i think there are some
layers to be uh to be pulled back there
that uh that would actually present a
bit of a teachable moment for all
parties concerned
marvin reese mayor of bristol thank you
very much indeed for your time this
morning
thank you